from Ridley Scott and Russell Crowe when
that still meant something comes the
sword and sandal movie that was so
successful it gave us Troy Alexander to
Hercules movies a Clash of the Titans
remake and another Ben Hur great
gladiator returned to the high point of
Rome sophistication for a film made
during the low point of our own where
limp Biskit ruled the charts mission
impossible to rule the box-office and
this movie won Best Picture I mean don't
get me wrong it kicks ass but the early
two-thousands do not deserve our
nostalgia Russell Crowe stars as Maximus
in the role that made him so famous he
thought he could get away with this
lez girls in the switch's
sure are you not entertained no no I am
not watch max take on every challenge in
his life with calm stoic acceptance calm
stoic dirt rubbing or calm stoic we
petting in this one Oh performance that
won him Best Actor strengthen on ah
strengthen honor but damn if that one no
doesn't give me pop did you have a name
my name is gladiator hell yeah thrill as
Maximus gets captured trained and forced
to do battle in what's basically a human
Pokemon League as he seeks revenge on
the off-putting weirdo Joaquin Phoenix
who in this movie plays the off-putting
weirdo Commodus witness one of the most
disturbing performances ever as the evil
emperor shows off as many daddy issues
this face is a waste
please sister issues stay with me
tonight
you know I won't you kiss me and a few
issues escape soap up his loft yo he's
basically Jaime Lannister if he couldn't
fight or command an army or bang his
sister or really do anything else right
enjoy a confusing makes a real history
and fake stuff they cut it is made up
featuring a real Roman Emperor who
suffers a made-up betrayal by his real
son who tries to kill this made-up
general who goes on to win real
gladiator games but when this real
emperor fights this fake gladiator which
really happened they pretend he died in
the arena when really his wrestling
partner strangled him in the bath hey it
might be fake but it's still a hundred
times more real and 300 why is it goat
there so strap in for the most well
executed pro wrestling story of all time
complete with a kick-ass man of the
people
supported by chanting crowds fighting an
evil authority figure who cheats to win
that ends with them beating the crap out
of each other in front of a screaming
crowd
hell yeah Maximus 3:16 says my name is
Maximus Decimus Meridius ok commander of
the armies of the North General of the
Felix legions uh-huh loyal servant to
the true Emperor Marcus Aurelius all
right father to a murdered son yeah
husband to a murdered wife wrap it up
and I will have my vengeance I got
things to do in this life or the next
yeah we're gonna have to work on your
catchphrase max no way that fits on a
t-shirt
starring Sparta crow Emperor Dumbledore
the first joacquin fonox Caesar
Flickerman Watteau and Little Caesars
Mad Maximus fury Rome this would be so
good you'll forget Hans Zimmer basically
reused it's music for Pirates of the
Caribbean
Hanz Bobby be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers hey screen junkies did
you know honest trailers was nominated
for an Emmy click the box on the left to
watch our shameless attempt to get the
TV Academy to vote for us
or better yet send it to an Emmy voter
you know and don't forget to check out
our rated movie fights with Seth Rogen
by clicking the box to the right it has
curse words and stuff I'm not going to
kill you I'm just gonna disappoint you
really really bad I reject your reality
and substitute my own
sprinkle turd doughnuts he's out there
somewhere lost scared so so handsome 300
lives of men I have walked on this earth
and now I have no time that was the joy
I was looking for